let's have a little chat I mean we've
been putting up all these over watch
your videos for the past week or so
shout out to everyone who's been helping
put that together Chris waters marrakesh
jean-luc in the back for helping me edit
them as well good good times ah but
let's talk about I guess our favorite
characters between the three of us what
are the characters that have spoken to
us maybe a character that you didn't
really like originally but you sort of
grown to love Mike McCarty you first of
all who you want to get the ball rolling
with the crush in Russian did because I
just know you yeah she's a real
character she's real difficult to learn
yeah she's a blend of a lot of different
roles she can she's like a support role
kind of by projecting shields on other
people and herself but then you have to
consider the fact that you're mainly
doing that not just a shield people
because they're pretty quick they
brought they dissipate after like only a
few seconds but that's mainly to buff
her Tesla cannons right damage which
that itself is also super different in
how you can use it because it's a
close-range like just concentrated laser
which if you and someone next to you are
both taking damage with shields that
thing's gonna be pretty powerful right
but it's also a grenade launcher that
has a little bits more less of an arc
than like junk rats grenade launcher not
as powerful as junk rats grenade
launcher or admit it's about as powerful
but it's doesn't not as high fire rate
so then you have that to consider but
then you also have her graviton surge
which is probably my favorite alt
because right it's devastating you can
pull it up it's not good by itself I
mean it can be if there's like two
people now you start grenade launching
if they don't know what's going on cuz
they're they're not defenseless they can
still shoot you right and do most some
of their abilities but most of the time
I find they just freaked out yeah like
everyone it's okay you can still do
stuff but like if the like I said if you
use Hanzo assault to just shoot the
arrow straight into them both Dragon's
tear them apart if you've liked Farrah's
just normal rocket launcher against them
is great junker at just launching the
grenades into it it's she's such a weird
blend of these different roles that I
every time I play I think about her
these different layers especially like
when you consider the map and how your
team composition and their your
opponent's composition factors into it
and I don't know I player differently
every time and it's it's really fun
that's awesome tell you what about
yourself who do you warm to on the
battlefield of overwatch gotta go may
all day may day may all day she's she's
a fun one she does so many things and I
just gravitate to characters that can
kind of support and heal themselves as
well so
I don't always have to depend on the
healer so she can ice block she doesn't
take damage she heals herself on top of
that you can technically use that to
block off shots like if there's a high
noon if you want to get really fancies
like re ice block hide behind me because
he can't high noon you yeah so that's
awesome and then you got the the wall
she can make to you know either kind of
move around to higher grounds or just to
kind of mess with the other team you
wall them off you block them off I've
blocked like a junk rat tire before I
walked the diva charging in before it's
like now you're not gonna buy that or
you know like if you get shutting it
down yeah exactly or like you know you
can really use it to split a team you
know sometimes just like get he look
like trap them you know like and both of
her you know her primary ability on her
gun and her secondary ability on her gun
are both amazing you know the first ones
just kind of like a you know like a
little blow dryer type effect but with
ice is like all right you're frozen now
I get to just right-click icicle you in
the head and you're probably doing
surprisingly powerful yeah like you can
destroy a Reinhardt pretty good with
that it's so annoying to play against
that to its own so frustrating cuz the
minute she starts doing it you're just
like running away I hate when people
play may well against me it's the most
infuriating thing yeah and yeah and then
her like icicle is like good to finish
people off that you freeze cuz like easy
head shot or it's good for like Nitish
like almost semi long range like I've
tried to out snipe a Widowmaker even
though it's like not a good idea but
it's kind of fun to try and her alts
another like kind of like fun wombo
combo type thing where it's really good
for you know stopping payloads or like
you know like really controlling a
capture point because when you throw it
it's like that whole like radius is
gonna be frozen yeah you don't want to
be in that so then it's like well
they're not gonna come here or issue
your whole team gets to just it's free
pickens at that point they're all frozen
like great combo that with the wall in
some interesting situations when there's
a block there exit and dump it on them
in the middle and speaking of
widow-makers I love Widowmaker so much
like I was such a huge team for like if
you were to know they give you the stats
of like how long you played each card
team fortress 2 my sniper is just like
all the way up here and what I love the
bed that him would overwatch is that
that sniper had two different weapons he
had the straight up like sniper rifle
but he also the crossbow which is
basically what Hanzo is
so Hans is good fun as well but man
widow-makers just like so much fun
because I just think there's something
about it because because there's always
these big fracas and because there's
these long lanes and you're essentially
watching a lot of people and having
fights pretty far away you can like just
dispense so much sadness on an
opposition team by having a good
Widowmaker by just like getting head
shots by taking our turrets but like
having them constantly worried where
they are like now all the time
especially if their other team doesn't
have a sniper who is either you know
cleaning up the your Widowmaker our
giving them like the sort of infrared
site I just she's so powerful if you can
pull it off right you can get into
interesting positions the grappling hook
allows you to like bail out of places
real quick if you need to you can change
where you are all the time the abilities
like charge up the shot I mean charging
up the shot getting a head shot like
it's just like the most satisfying thing
ever and then just even just popping
away people when you've got like fifty
percent charge just to mock their health
down she's just like part of me feels
like in in the right hands a Widowmaker
can win a game like oh yeah just destroy
people um like we'd some interesting
games last night where I felt like I was
like doing some good way to making yeah
I was like one game I was eighty-six
percent of the game on fire yeah and it
was only because these folks didn't know
what to do right and the only counter I
feel that's really good against her is
either a really good Farah who's able to
flank and dump down some shots or an
opposition Widowmaker and then it
becomes a counter-strike cuz you're like
having this headshot hunch right where
you're like I need to get the headshot
cuz I'm not you're gonna get it yeah I
just I think she's obviously fantastic
I've been switching to Reaper to counter
her lately all right and I'm not the
best Reaper play okay I think you're the
more experienced Reaper player um but
yeah just warming up next to her is the
most satisfying thing and if you do it
right she's not gonna see like you come
from like behind cover right sir and
years are the shotguns pointed her head
right there yeah that's like figuring
out the counters in this game was so fun
to cuz like Farah is tough yeah really
tough you need some skill to take down
Farah in the air for most characters but
yeah I don't know like McCree's another
character he's probably my second second
favorite main yeah why do you like about
him he's just a dirty player and I love
that like he once you figure out the
loop between not that it's the same loop
every time because i think it that
falls into a trap of being okay
flashbang fan the hammer dodge on mega
reload fan the hammer yeah maybe die
we're walking away but if you do it
right you know when to just use the
primary single shot which is really
precise and I think they nerfed it since
the first early access because it was
pretty the single shot yeah yeah I was
like to find the range got a little
nerve because it was like did like
choice Eagle County oh yeah yeah totally
I mean like we were talking to Jack
alpha batted he said that at one stage
he was at McCree was able t was
basically long-range me in mid range on
short range yeah and it's funny you say
kind of like deagle because the the gun
is actually modeled after the cult and
half-life 10 remember that designate a
lot cold whatever called python i think
it was and cobra now python yeah yeah I
am it's has that same kick back as well
which is such a great feeling you're
like playing 1998 half-life yeah blowing
people up with this thing that's the
best thing and well also you have his
dead I which rise I showed you a
highlight this morning I'm proud of it
what map was that was it Dorado maybe or
where was the neutral control point mode
but uh I walked up the stairs and
usually want to start dead i'm pretty
far away because you're vulnerable
telling me he doesn't have much health
to begin with and he's moved slowly but
a few time dead i right and you come
around the corner and I saw three people
locked on because you're I was pretty
close killed those three came around the
corner soldier 76 came on the control
zone over time flash bang him fan the
hammer we like pretty much one like
that's that kind of loop with him that i
love but he's still he still you have to
be practice with him right because it's
really vulnerable and you need to know
that timing and when to use primary when
to fan the hammer because if you don't
have that Dodger already the reloads
like the you know that reloading the six
snapping the chamber back in yeah he
just feels awesome that's the same
reason I lil Farah because it's a
similar kind of thing where you can very
easily get killed very quickly with her
if you don't protect yourselves from
like turrets and widow-makers but apart
from that if you can like get a handle
on them and you know where not to jump
in the air like super early you can just
like rain death on people all the time
it's like getting above groups of people
when they're fighting each other and
just lot landing rockets tan like
flanking widow-makers and taking the
marriage taking a turrets from miles
away because your Rockets are so
powerful and they're so far away that
you can just like I don't know it's
she's able to control a long way
people and then also like my favorite
part in this not for showing that when
you can get inside of that area or
inside of any of these areas and light
up into the air inside of the control
good point and just kill people you just
you just jump it up hovering hovering
hovering and then jumping up hovering
and just rockets and rockets rockets and
like people don't have an answer for I
mean the only answer is either a decent
sniper or a turret so it's so much fun
what about you right it is a thing of
beauty I watched you playing this
morning was like okay I got to steal
some of these maneuvers cuz like you
know you can rock a job and hover but
like I watch you play and it's like oh
this is like a whole different animal
but um I'm gonna name a character that I
didn't think I would like okay but then
I think I'm starting to like and I was
even more jealous today when you got the
the the I think was like the Ifrit oh
yeah duh skin because I gotta yeah I got
that at the end of beta and I was like I
gotta play him now that I had that skin
right and I think that's part of the the
the hook of the skins is a try like you
get another character kind of makes me
want to play that character just like oh
that looks way cool i should try and you
wouldn't think to play it notice um
anything i like him he's pretty low
health he's like 75 health and like 75
shield yeah but his discord orb which is
basically a debuff on the on the
opposing enemies like it just makes them
like nothing it's like all your
Reinhardt not really not anymore amer
right yeah its armor um but he's he he's
deceptively strong i thinking like
offensively too because like his orbs
can go pretty far I like out snipe the
Widowmaker I'm guessing she was bad but
like with zenyatta I mean we had a run
on the live stream radio today where
Chris played zenyatta and and you were
playing with him actually you were Ryan
on a map and he just destroyed everyone
I've never seen anything like I didn't
realize that this guy was so he's the
most like offensive sabor character by a
mile he was destroying everyone he was D
buffing everyone and then just like
pounding those balls yeah and I didn't
realize yeah the distance yeah pound
those balls I didn't realize the
distance you get on those things like ya
know you know he can get it's like
pretty long range yeah and so like he's
pretty vulnerable when you get up close
to him but his best like kind of
maneuver is his right click he basically
charges like fights and then he just
lets it all risks you can like take a
turret
done everything yeah so you just like
kind of cute up especially like if a
widow makers got the infrared you kind
of cue it up before you round the corner
yeah yeah surprise yeah because she
hasn't got that much out either yeah and
is all just amazing because like you
have to respect it like when he's all
ting it's like okay I guess the whole
team's just gonna get healed for like a
lot and they're gonna have this control
point and I don't we don't know what to
do I think Chris had the best like
scenario where it's like the Reinhardt
just kind of like pins him away but like
you don't take damage but like that
takes the heel away from the rest of but
that's that's a key only thing I could
think is a good caution blaster far I
just yeah and they'll want them off but
that done this like new CEO come in
right yeah yeah but this is great yeah
yeah cuz Lucio if he's healing everybody
he well not when he drops the beat but
when he does the let's break raise the
roof oh yes are yeah whatever it's
called he he's vulnerable you still kill
him while he's doing that same with
mercy you can kill her whatever right I
he you just had to [ __ ] they're gonna be
healed yeah yeah you have to do
something c'mon here there you go
overwatch that's some of our favorite
characters let us know yours are in the
comments below I mean that's the most
exciting thing about this game is that
like everyone's got a different one and
it's not just based on some you know
stupid aesthetic thing or we're not like
forcing it it's like it's a genuinely
just these these characters are just so
well created like both in terms of how
they look but also just gameplay wise so
unique like each of us here and most
people playing the game probably look at
overwatch completely differently but
totally different favorite characters
like the game looks so much different
from a widow makers perspective than it
does from a Winston that's why I place
Farah and Widowmaker I'm basically
paying team fortress I'm a soldier or
the sniper like I'm playing the same
people I've ever always played in video
games I'm playing quake and I'm playing
counter-strike like it's crazy I think
to the reason why it's kind of like you
have memories too I think like they're
ours like not even just play the games
but you have all these memorable
scenarios of like okay you're gonna
remember that high noon you did right
like for a while now and I think as long
as it keeps creating these memories it
makes it like even a more long lasting
game because you always like those are
things you want to talk about like oh
yeah I was man I did this you know and
and that's kind of like what makes this
game fun it's like
day something different can happen but
you'll remember that and it'll be like
oh that was awesome yeah crazy stuff